so as we start to think about this
contracting economy uh their
expectation or or their kind of promise
to the markets that they're going to
keep raising interest rates the market
uh as of maybe two weeks ago was still
thinking there was going to be 10
interest rate increases this year there
was going to be a 300 basis point
interest rate by the end of the year uh
is your expectation that they'll
continue to raise rates all the way
through the year or will they at some
point pause it do we maybe get a rate
cut at some point what are you expecting
to happen with interest rates yeah all
of those things i mean i think they will
pause the increases and maybe eventually
reduce rates we'll see but even if they
just pause the increases that counts as
an easing uh they they've taken back
what they've promised to deliver and
remember as inflation continues to get
higher and higher and higher
real interest rates keep falling even if
the fed doesn't officially reduce
nominal rates if the inflation rate goes
from eight percent to ten percent or
twelve
and the fed's still got the fed funds
rate you know wherever it ends up being
1 or 2
then rates are effectively being reduced
but you have to remember that the rate
hikes that the fed is promising are
inadequate they're not promising to
raise rates nearly enough to actually
bend the inflation curve and bring it
back down to two percent you're not
going to take eight percent inflation
and make it two percent inflation by
taking zero percent interest rates and
making them two or three percent that is
still a historically ultra stimulative
monetary policy but more important than
just the interest rates it's the
quantity of money that is important the
fed has to massively withdraw
money from circulation and what the
public doesn't understand is it's had
this massive increase in the size of
government nobody's taxes have been
raised nobody's benefits have been cut
so where did all this government come
from how did we afford this massive
expansion in government we paid for it
through inflation we printed a bunch of
money right we ran these big deficits
the federal reserve monetized the
deficits and we paid for government with
inflation now the public is demanding
lower inflation well inflation is simply
the way we pay for all the government
that the public also demanded well you
don't have a free lunch so the only way
to get rid of the inflation is to pay
for government some other way with
taxation so the only way to lower
inflation is to raise taxes on the
middle class substantially not on the
rich there's not enough money there plus
if you tax the rich you reduce
investment that's a problem you need to
tax the middle class or the poor because
that reduces spending and that's what
the government has to do they have to
stop people from spending money they
didn't earn meaning money that's not
associated with productive activity you
can't just spend money unless you help
produce stuff to give that money value
the problem is we've been printing all
this money instead of paying taxes now
people think oh you're heartless peter
you want the middle class and the poor
to pay higher taxes i don't what i would
rather see is the government slash
spending cut spending on the military
cut spending on social security and
medicare and all sorts of things you
know get rid of the space force that
donald trump you know stuff we have to
cut government spending i'd rather do
that now of course that's going to
affect the middle class because a lot of
middle class people are drawing social
security checks but unfortunately the
government has to tell the truth to the
american public either we drastically
cut government spending dramatically
raise taxes or inflation is here to stay
right we can't get rid of inflation
without cutting government spending or
raising taxes but either way it's the
middle class that is going to foot the
bill do you expect the federal reserve
at some point in the next 24 months to
change their two percent inflation
target to two and a half three percent
like will they change that target
inflation rate you know it's it it would
really be
a ridiculous to do that because let's
say inflation is eight or ten percent
you know does it matter if you raise the
target from two to two and a half i mean
you're nowhere near two and a half i
think they would look ridiculous
to raise the target when they're still
miles away now let's say they raised the
target to seven or eight percent you
know but that would scare the hell out
of the markets they would never do that
so i don't know if they're ever going to
raise the target i i just don't think
they'll ever get close enough to two
percent
to to even
you know have a rational basis for doing
that i mean that would assume that hey
they got down to two and a half percent
and they're like you know what this is
as low as we're going to get let's just
raise our target rather than try to get
it down an extra half a percent but i
don't think they're ever going to come
close enough that they they would look
too ridiculous to lower a target that
they're not even
close to in the next decade what do you
think the lowest inflation rate that
we're gonna see is do you can they get
it under five percent can they get it
under three percent what do you think is
possible uh for them to actually achieve
well they could i just think they're not
willing to do what it takes to do it
right okay sure anything is possible but
what's probable what are vote-seeking
politicians more likely to do
and so in my mind the most
logical way that they're gonna get the
cpi below five percent is to rig it some
more is to make more changes in the cpi
so that a 12 inflation rate will be
recorded as a four and a half percent
inflation rate right so they're not
going to actually get
the rate down they just may succeed in
lying about how high the rate is by
coming up with additional ways to change
the cpi in fact they've already done
that they made some changes to the cpi
in the beginning of this year that it
probably is probably going to shave a
little bit off of it and that's why they
did it but inflation is so high that
even if they knock off one percent or
two percent based on you know rigging
the books you know it's still a big
number